basically in uh you know the black
background and uh and white uh things
and that's also the environment i'm
gonna show you some demo code as well um
so that might be a little bit difficult
to see if you're sitting in the back so
you might wanna move uh you know forward
i've tried to increase the scaling of
the
of the of my screen as much as possible
so but now you have been warned um we
have we have room here in the front
all right so um
i just gave another talk and i just need
to reset my brain a little bit to see
what what what is this one about
all right
got it all right so um so like sudden
back in the
2014 2015 time frame
i am i was asked by one of my recurring
clients to come back and help them out
as a freelance software developer you
know i've done some work for them before
and and then they you know i went on to
do other things and then i came back
because they wanted my help with some
stuff as well
and they've been pretty busy while i was
gone and this team was a as it was a
team of very skilled developers so they
had lots of
you know great things that they did and
one of the things that they did while i
was gone was that they'd enable in a
continuous delivery um so i learned a
lot about continuous delivery from from
these people um so that's sort of like
the organization they were they were
really good at what they were doing
but this talk is not about continuous
delivery um it's about another
interesting thing that they did because
also while i've i've been gone
what um they've implemented a locking
system in their production system so
whenever you know the production code
was running it would log uh to um i
think they they use this um elk stack as
far as i remember
um
so um so we started you know i started
helping them you know creating new
features and so on and you know once in
a while when you create new features you
inadvertently create bugs as well
so sometimes you know
we would get bug reports
and this happens it was it was a pretty
good code base we actually did a lot of
things or they had already done a lot of
things right so we didn't have that many
bugs but you know they came up from time
to time and then i found out that you
know if if the bug was you know precise
enough that we could identify
uh you know when things went wrong and
sort of you know how you know which part
of the system went wrong we could prob
we could usually find you know just from
the bug report we could find the logs
you know the log entries that related to
that particular behavior
and from that it turned out that we
could always
on you know get an understanding of what
went wrong and reproduce the problem and
based on the logs you know the
understanding that we gained from the
logs and that turned out to be
repeatedly
you know an experience that we had
so um so i thought that was interesting
um and i you know it couldn't really
it was very pleasant to work with
because it took a lot of stress away
from understanding defects in the system
you sort of like you go and look at the
logs and you look through the logs a
little bit and say okay now i pretty
much understand it i can reproduce that
i say as as a unit test or things like
that
um so when i went on my own way you know
after the engagement and ended i am i
started i couldn't really stop thinking
about you know what
what was it that made
that logging uh you know such a as a
useful thing because
they didn't log a lot of stuff actually
they just um they just like the right
you know they locked that stuff that we
needed in order to reproduce problems
so i thought that was interesting
did they know something that i didn't
know or you know did it did it just
turned out that they were lucky
and
these people were really skilled but and
you know to be honest in this particular
instance i actually think it turns out
that they were lucky um there were
circumstances around how that you know
code base worked and the entire
environment that it was running in where
it was quite obvious that there were
things you wanted to log and you know
they went ahead and and did that but i
still couldn't really shake the idea of
you know what's the right amount of
logging
um so based on that experience with
having this very nice uh you know uh
stress-free interaction with you know
just enough locking i i thought you know
there's actually there's a
you can actually apply a method to that
so this is what that talk this talking
about it's about what to log and also a
little bit about how to log and actually
got to spend most of the time on what to
log
so um
usually when i when i visit other
organizations so not the one that i used
to talk about right now but other
organizations code often looks like this
so you have a lot of you know code that
is um sprinkled with you know
liberal you know use of lockdown debug
and
and lock.info or whatever else you might
you might have and there's so much stuff
going on there that's it's noise that
actually makes it hard to understand
what the code is actually doing
and
i should probably be um we should
probably just to spend a little time you
know discussing what it is that we are
looking at here so uh this is um you
know one of my patented um
online restaurant reservations you know
system demos
it's it's not patented but uh but but
i've been using this you know this kind
of demo application for a long time you
know it's one of those things where um
you you scroll you know you you find a
website or you use an app and then you
fill in some details about the
reservations that you'd like to to do
and then you can press the submit button
and this slide shows you how long i've
been using uh this particular you know
demo scenario so i'd like to reuse my
slides um so i copied that in so i've
been doing this for many years now but
the point is this type of system what
we're looking at here is you press the
submit button it creates a json document
it posts the json document to an http
service somewhere and the code that
we're going to look at is you know the
http side of things so not the
client the code that actually does that
but the code that receives that json
document that's that's what we're
looking at here at the moment you know
there's there's this post method it
takes a dto that's basically just the
data from the from the json document and
then it you know does stuff with it but
you almost can't tell what it is that
it's doing because there's all of that
locking stuff going on
um so i don't think code should look
like this i'd like you know code to look
like this
so so this is more easy to read because
there's there isn't all of that noise
um
so um write code like that
but then you might say well yeah but
mark you know
you just remove all the logging
so um
we need logs
you can't just remove all the logging
and say just because it's more readable
you can save it let's throw away all the
logging that's not what i did actually
this code it turns out actually logs uh
we'll get back to how that works later
on um
before we do that i think we should just
talk a little bit about you know why do
we actually log because this is more
than one reason you know as developers
we'd often you know think of ourselves
first so we think okay so we can do you
know various things where you know where
we lock debug information or other
things that enable us to troubleshoot
things you know when things go wrong in
production and that's logging for our
own purposes which is fine
but there are other reasons as well so
maybe other you know departments would
like you to log you know other
types of things so maybe the business
for example would like you to log you
know things that are important to them
what we'd typically call you know key
performance in indicators so stuff like
you know how many sales are you having
or how many page views or whatever else
you think might be interesting and if
you're operating in a domain where you
you know you are covered by law or
regulations you might also be required
to you know leave behind an audit trade
which is also a sort of locking so
there's at least these three you know
wide
you know reasons why you'd like to log
there might be others as well but i
actually can't think of them but that's
what i think i think captures most of it
and but what they have in common is that
you have a running system and that
running system produces some you know
some output that you can sort of peruse
at at your own leisure at a later time
so it's typically to some sort of out of
process system
uh so we if we define logging that
broadly that's all logging and that's
that's pretty much uh it doesn't turns
out that it doesn't really matter that
much you know which which of those use
cases you have
so
it's probably clear that we we don't
want to log too much because if you've
ever tried one of those turnkey
solutions where you basically can you
know you know click a little button or
you know download some sort of framework
and then it will instrument all your
code and then you can try to run that in
production you probably know that it
generates tons of data very very quickly
if you lock everything that's not really
practical because it's going to generate
so much data that you probably can't fit
it on your storage devices or if you're
running in the cloud
you don't want to pay the price for that
and also just the act of locking
everything that's going on in the system
it's probably going to slow down the
system so there's a limit to how much
you want to log on the other hand you
also don't want to lock too little for
obvious reasons because if there's too
little information in your locks
you can't use it for troubleshooting
maybe you're not you know complying with
the regulations or the business doesn't
feel that it has you know good enough
insights into what's going on so there's
also you know logging too little so
obviously what we don't want to do we
want to lock just the right amount of
data so this is almost like this fairy
tale with you know with a girl who comes
into a house that is empty at the moment
that she's trying out all the food
that's left and she's trying the beds
and so on and some of it's just a little
bit too much and some of it is a little
bit little
but you know the middle thing is just
right okay so that's that's what we're
aiming for so obviously for that reason
that kind of locking we're going to call
that goldilocks at golgi logging okay
um so
so so what what does that actually mean
so we sort of need to figure out okay so
what is goldilocking um so what to log
so um the key lies in repeatability so
this is sort of like a theme that we've
seen in software development for the
last few decades is that we you know
repeatable bills are interesting that's
something that we actually want to
strive for
repeatable deployments is the thing that
we might want to strive for so what
we're going to do here is what we're
going to look at something called
repeatable execution and that's the term
that i just made up um but the idea is
that we should be able to repeat that
the execution that happened in
production you know based on what's in
the log and we can sort of replay that
afterwards
and um there's a there's a method to the
madness and and we can start looking at
a code like this so so here we have uh
you know two um two integers that are
being added together x and y are two
integers and we produce z uh which is
another integer from that so first of
all would you like something like this
and uh it's it seems a little bit it
seems a little bit odd to say adding x
and y
but on the other hand you may not know
what x and y are because you know if
this is something that arrives from from
outside of your system it could be the
user who's entering you know in a user
interface they're entering two numbers
and then you're adding them together
i don't think it makes much sense to us
to to lock that you're adding them
together but if they're arriving from
outside of your system it makes sense to
log what the values are so you could
sort of think of that as sort of like a
variation on that at least log what x
and y are that might make sense if if
they're they if they're external values
but at least we could say something else
you know would you log what the result
is
it doesn't make sense if you know what x
and y is this is entirely redundant
because if you know those two numbers
you can also you can always just
recalculate you can run the calculation
again in order to get z
you don't need to actually lock what z
was because it is repeatable
all right so this is a function this is
a very simple mathematical function you
know x plus y
um and in general you know mathematical
functions have to have this
quality that you can always just repeat
them and they always produce the same
output that turns out to be a really
interesting quality of functions in
general it's one of the many reasons why
functional programming is such an
interesting thing because we're working
with functions and we really like these
things called pure functions for a lot
of reasons so
we can learn from functional programming
in terms of you know what is what do we
have to log and what don't we have to
log so in functional programming we
really like these things called pure
functions
and pure function is a function that has
some some extra qualities associated
with it so one of them is determinism
you know the same input will always
produce the same output that's what we
just saw by adding numbers together or
in general that works for mathematics
but it also works for a lot of other
things so if you want to you know
reverse the string through that is
always oof uh and and and and such
and going on like that so um so that you
can actually write a lot of complicated
complex behavior as pure functions by
just being deterministic that's one side
of the coin another thing you need to do
is you need to make sure that there are
no side effects so side effect is
something that changes the observable
state of the system
so sending an email or you know deleting
a file on disk or creating a row in a
database even repainting the screen is
actually a side effect something that a
pure function can't do
so it's worthwhile being aware of the
pure functions are
have a lot of nice you know
qualities when when they have these two
qualities there's a lot of other
niceties that sort of follow from that
it makes the functions much easier to
unit test and also you know you can
repeat the execution so there's a lot of
nice things about that but on the other
hand we need to understand that since we
can't do side effects we can't really do
anything that changes the state of the
world and then you know in a
philosophical sense all software is
exists in order to change the state of
the world
at least it exists to make money for
some person and you know that's also
changing the state of the world um so we
can't really do anything useful if we
can't do side effects and also you know
having something that is
non-deterministic like you know
generating a random number or reading
contents of a disk or you know getting
the current time
that's non-deterministic behavior we
can't do that with pure functions as
well so it seems quite limiting
and it turns turns out it's not actually
that limiting but there will be a
residual
of things where we need you know we need
state changes and we need
non-deterministic code and we call those
things impure actions so it's not that
in functional programming that we can't
do impure things it's just that we want
to favor pure functions because they're
easy to unit test they're easy to reason
about um it turns out we don't need to
to lock what happens inside of a pure
function because we can always just you
know run it again whereas the impure
actions they are non-deterministic they
may you know may have side effects
so they are you know more difficult to
work with so we'd like to minimize the
the use of those things
um so that's sort of like the general
idea
so
if we're looking at a little bit of a
piece of sharp code like this one for
example so um so i'm not assuming that
you're a sharp developer but if you're
familiar with that sort of you know c
based language you can probably follow
along here
um you might ask yourself if we're
trying to validate whether the dto is
valid or not um is that a pure function
or not
and you can't really tell at this level
of abstraction because you know
c sharp or java or typescript or you
know basically any mainstream language
even if sharp doesn't allow you to
actually make that sort of decision so
in order to answer that question you
have to go and look at the source code
in order to actually look at it and say
does it do any sort of you know
non-deterministic behavior so this is
very this is a very simple example just
that's just to get the point across so
the the protocol here is that if we
return the empty string uh that's sort
of like an error message and an empty
error message indicates that there are
no there's no error on the other hand if
we return a string that's not empty that
indicates an error that means the the
detail is not valid
so
we might ask ourselves you know are
there any side effects here and it
doesn't look like it's sending email or
you know changing things on disk or
anything else so there's no side effects
is it deterministic well it's not
relying on the on on any sort of random
number generator or it's not reading
from disk or anything like that so
yeah it's actually deterministic so you
know by looking through the source code
we can determine that yes this is
actually a pure function
but but we have a problem and that is
you know if if
we might have a stakeholder that comes
by later on and tells us well you know
your validation code is fine as
you know it's it's not wrong
but it's not capturing all the things
that might you know that we might want
to reject so for example if people are
posting trying to create a reservation
in the past
that doesn't really make any sense we
can't accept a reservation in the past
so we should consider that to be invalid
as well and you go and say okay so i can
deal with that i'm going to you know
change the code a little bit and i'm
going to say if the date is less than
datetime.now i'm also going to consider
that an invalid date
now this turns out to be
non-deterministic because if you if you
have you know code like this where you
say the input isn't completely known on
beforehand and then you run the code now
if you we're trying to make a
reservation on the 20th of january 2020
as you can tell the slides are a bit old
now something happened in 2020 that sort
of made me not being able to actually
run this presentation back then
um
but if um if you're running this code on
the 19th you'll get you know just an
empty message meaning you know all is
valid and then if you run it two days
later you're gonna get an error message
saying this is an embedded date so the
same input um but now the output is
different so that's considered
non-deterministic
so so that's a bit of a problem um you
know determining whether things are pure
or impure is is actually not that easy
but you can go and read the source code
and in a very simple example that the
one that i just showed you here it's
sort of fairly obvious but if you have a
lot of code and your code calls some
other code that calls some other code
and so on the thing about you know
purity or impurity is that it's
transitive so if you have something that
calls impure code the caller is also
impure and the caller of that is impure
and and so on
um
so um so it's it's difficult to actually
identify that so it'd be really nice if
there was a tool instead of you know
using our own brains for that and i have
good news and i have bad news here
because the good news is such a tool
does exist
the bad news is that it doesn't exist
for any of the mainstream languages that
you know so you know c-sharp java
typescript
you know python
javascript even if sharp closure
whatever such a tool doesn't exist
because the tool is a language and
there's more than one language but sort
of the biggest language that does this
thing that that actually can make that
distinction is a language called haskell
and i'm not assuming that you know
anything about haskell at all so i'm
going to give you a
very quick crash course in how that
actually works so haskell uses its type
system to make the distinction between
things that are pure and things that are
on impure and
with that type system
you can actually if you've defined a
function to be pure and then you're
trying to call an impure action from
your pure function the code's not going
to compile so that's basically how it
works
so you're using the type system in order
to to determine whether things are pure
or not so a crash course in just reading
type or function signatures in haskell
look goes like this so on the left hand
side you have the name of a function so
i am pure is the name of a function the
two colons is basically just a delimiter
from you know between the name and then
the type of the function you can think
of that as a method signature like in c
sharp but
and you read those from
from left to right
so so the input is on the left hand side
and you might have more than one input
but here we just have one and then to
the right most side you have the output
and these are types so we actually in
this case we have a type called input
and we have another type called output
just to make things a little bit more
explicit a little bit explicit so this
is this is a pure function
and it's probably easier to see how that
is a pure function if i show you what an
impure action looks like as you can see
the mpi action looks almost like the
pure function except that it has this
little modifier called i o
so if you have this modifier that's at
this i o modifier means that's an impure
action so by order of elimination if
that i o modifier is not there then by
default things are pure and haskell so
you have to explicitly say that things
are impure otherwise they're just pure
by default
so that's basically how the how you can
distinguish you know between impure
actions and pure functions uh at the
type level
which is which is pretty nice
um
so um
you might then ask yourself okay so if
you if you were doing this in haskell if
you want to validate whether another
reservation is in the future if you want
if you did that in haskell how would you
go about doing you know solving that
problem and here's just one way of doing
it and again
i i don't expect you to actually be able
to read the haskell code it's not really
important just focus on the two top
lines which is the function declaration
so we have this thing called validate
reservation that's a function and then
you know i ran out of space so i had to
move the type declaration to a new line
that's possible you can do that
so you'll see here we have more than one
inputs but the output is something
called either string reservation d2 and
don't worry if you don't understand what
that means the point that i'm trying to
get across here is we look for the i o
modifier and we don't find it and that
means this is a pure function this is
basically how how that works
so how do we solve solve the problem of
you know looking at the current time and
seeing whether the reservation is in the
past or in the future now it's a really
dumb
you know the primitive
solution to that we just pass in the
value that represents what time it is
right now as an argument to the function
and then the function just deals with
that value so translate it to c sharp it
might look like this we have you know a
now argument and then we're just you
know checking on that and that's a pure
function
it's a very common thing to do in
functional programming and you might say
okay so but that but that's that you
know
that's cheating or
some people might say that breaks
encapsulation and i'll argue that it
doesn't but that leads into a discussion
of what encapsulation means
um or you know you might just say but
mark aren't you aren't you concerned
that um
you know people may call this function
with you know with a value that's not
daytime now they may call this function
with the value that is in 2030 or a
value that is in 1980 or you know
something else
and and basically you can say well i'm
not concerned for a couple of reasons
first of all there's no side effects
here so it doesn't matter what they do
and also i'm not concerned because i i
think that's actually an advantage
because that means instead of just
running on the system clock you can now
perform simulations so you can write
unit tests that that will you know test
what's going to happen if i run this
code in 2030
or what would happen you know
you know in other
sorts of circumstances or you can use
your you know data from your locking
system to say
what actually happened yesterday when
this code ran you know you can pass
those values in and that enables you to
to perform simulations and that's repeat
repeatable execution
there's a it's basically just a it's one
of those many
benefits that just fall out of pure
functions because you can always do that
with pure functions
um so that's considered an advantage so
it's not cheating it's actually a very
good thing to do it this way all right
so um
so i'm not i'm not trying to suggest
that you should now go and throw away
all your mainstream code bases and
rewrite everything in haskell now if you
want to do that
please hire me to help you i would love
to do that but you know that's not
that's not really my it's not about my
agenda here um what i find haskell
really interesting for is as a thinking
tool so i use haskell for proofs of
concept so for example if i want to
learn you know i have this
red online restaurant reservation system
and i'd like to write
as much of it as pure functions and just
just only the things that cannot be pure
functions i'll need to you know sort of
isolate those
and treat them differently but i'd like
to know in a system like that you know
what's what's impure what's essentially
impure what can i not get away from you
know being impure and how much stuff can
i actually do as pure functions so you
know writing a prototype and haskell
will enable me to
to sort of answer that sort of question
so that's what i did and again i'm not
expecting you to know any haskell so i'm
just going to briefly walk you through
some of the type signatures here so in
the code base that we're looking at the
moment here this is my basic my domain
model so this is where i model you know
what a reservation looks like what a
valid reservation looks like uh this is
how i make decisions about you know
whether or not i can accept the
reservation or not so here we have a
little bit more of a sophisticated
version of a validation function and
again if we're looking for this i o
modifier you'll notice that nothing here
even if we've you know
i've split this in multiple lines
there's nothing that says i o here so
this is a pure function and we can sort
of scroll down this
this file here and look at just the
function signatures and nowhere will you
find the i o modifier and that means
this entire domain model here is
actually written as pure functions and
the um we'll get back to this try accept
function later on
this is sort of like the core decision
logic that makes use of a lot of those
those other functions uh you know
in this in this file so when i post a
json document this it ends up calling
this tri-accept method that then makes
the decision can we or can we not accept
that particular reservation and again
you'll notice you know the output the
the output type here looks really
horrible if you don't know what that
means uh that's really not something
that you know i'm gonna try to explain
to you in two minutes because i can't
the point is there's no i o modifier
here so it's a pure function
um so that's nice it's nice to know that
you can write a lot of the of actually
all the business decision logic as pure
functions now on the other hand it turns
out that you know interacting with
something like sql server this is
actually saving things in sql server
that is not something that is possible
to do as pure functions these need to be
impure actions basically anything that
performs i o
is impure hence the name of that
modifier i o so you can see it's sitting
here
this is a an action that inserts a row
into the database we have other things
down here
read reservation this reads a single
reservation or it tries to read a single
reservation it says io right here
read reservations is a query that gives
us a collection of reservations back
based on a predicate uh or criterion um
and it says i o here so we have a clear
distinction between things that are you
know impure and things that are pure and
it's nice to know which you know which
bucket things need to fall in
so so that's that's there's that point
now i i did oversimplify things a little
bit when i said that this is the way you
distinguish between pure and impure
there's actually a generalization of
that impurity here where sometimes
you'll see things look like this where
it says monet iom and then there's an m
that m refers back to the monad i o and
if you see that in modifier and the
modifier you know refers back to
something called monet io that is also
impure this is sort of like a
generalization of that i o modifier
there and don't worry if you don't
understand it it's just that you know
that's the sort of stuff that we go
looking for
so we can see down here at the bottom i
have this little um
this is sort of like an interpreter and
we can get back to that in a little
while um but this is basically it takes
a little domain specific language and
runs an interpreter over the database
and you can see this sort of example
here monad moon iom and then the m
appears over here so that's an impure
function as uh action as well so the way
that you basically you know you have
these pure functions and the pure
functions can't call into the database
but then you still need to do the
database stuff which is impure so how do
i sort of how do you sort of compose
those two things together
and you do that at the entry point
basically so um it also turns out that
you know doing anything evolving the
system clock is also impure because it's
non-deterministic so you can again see
this monit iom here
and so on so what i've done here is that
i've created some some code that can
enable me to sort of interleave pure
function pure code with impure actions
via a set of interpreters that all are
all running and being impure
and then what i can do is i have this
thing called lock clock which is also
impure but it's sort of like a wrapper
around actually accessing the system
clock and what this wrapper does it just
locks
you know whenever you know i'm doing
something that is an impure action it's
writing that information to a log and
the same thing goes with this thing
called log reservation it's just
wrapping around the actual access to sql
server but it is it's locking all the
information so sort of like the
decorator design pattern
um
right okay so um so let's have a look at
that as well so
this this system is actually an entire
system it's just a very thin slice so
it's sort of like a proof of concept but
it actually it does work it can't do
http traffic it can save in in sql
server of all things you know getting
haskell to talk to sql server was kind
of interesting i had to send a few pull
requests i sent some pool requests in
2019 and they were just merged last week
basically so
i think the the original maintainer of
that system had other things to do
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to start the web server
i'm gonna need a connection string to my
database i'm just running the database
on my local db here so i am i can't
remember the um
i can't remember the the syntax of that
so i'm just gonna i've kept that in a
file i'm just gonna put that you know
contents in my clipboard and then i'm
going to run the application so let's
see uh
so it's not that it's anything secret
the contents are right here um i'm using
integrated authentication so there's no
um there's no passwords here so now the
server is running is running on port
8080 um so now i need to figure out a
way to post a json document to to port
8080 on my local machine so i'm going to
use another um
another
terminal for that so i can use curl
that's my preferred thing you know do
yourself a favor if you're doing any
sort of http work use curl it just makes
things easier because curl is always
around someone told me yesterday that
curl is actually running on the mass
rovers on mars i'm sort of working you
know it's getting my head around okay so
what's the what's the ping time of tcp
ip from mars to the earth it's like 8 28
minutes something like that
so how does that work i mean i'm not
sure i understand that okay so what i
want to do is i want to post to a
resource called reservations i'm going
to need to give it a content type i'm
going i'm going to need to tell it it's
application slash json because otherwise
you know there's a little bit of content
negotiation going on there and then i
want to write my um
my json document so the way it's
designed i need to give it an id the id
needs to be a um
the idea needs to be a and a good
so let's see if i can do this and then
like this um so i need to create a new
guide so i can use this thing called the
uuid gen uh uuid gen so that's just
going to create every time i run this
code i'm just going to create a new good
if i've done things correctly
i'm going to need a date
so i'm just going to use the date of
tomorrow so 2022.0603
and at nineteen hundred
and um
i'm gonna need a name for the person
named for the reservation so we're gonna
say ill burrows
is gonna make the the reservation we
need an email address for ill
so that's going to be elbows
at example.com
like that and we need a quantity that's
the last thing
and and we'll you know try to make a
reservation for two people does that
look okay to you did i make it do you
like forget any quotes or things no
okay let's let's try it out
it's always a little bit stressful here
okay so it says 200 okay so um it looks
like it's worked so
just as a sanity check we can go i have
actually have access to the um to the
database sitting here in
in sql server so if i go and refresh
that we should now see a row in the
database so if if this demo had been
running if i'd been doing this in 2002
you'd be very impressed but you know
yeah you can have an http thing that
actually ends up in a database
but that's really not the point of the
demo the point of the demo is that while
this happened um
the system logged all the mpl actions
so where do you wanna where do you
always put your log files on the desktop
obviously
this is just proof of concept code right
so in this case it's looking like this
um so this is basically just something
that you know there's a format i choose
to use because that's that's machine
readable to haskell code it's basically
just sort of like serialized haskell
code um but what we can see here from
the entries is i you know the first
thing that happened is that you know
part of the system you know ask for the
current time there's no input to that
question because you're just asking what
the what is the current time but then
the output was this particular value
then the system asked you know made a
query against the database read the
existing reservations you know using
this particular date as input it got you
know the empty collection as output
because there's no prior reservations in
the database
then it you know called this method
called create reservation and it also
locked what the what the input was and
if we scroll to the end we can see the
output is is nothing this is called unit
but it basically means void as output
and then i also log the entire
http
request and response so that's why
you're seeing a lot of you know escaped
strings here because there's sort of the
strings that i escape within strings and
so on so that's a little bit confusing
um but that's that's basically what
happened um so um so what i can do is
that i can start let's see on my
haskell prompt here i'm going to stop
the web server and i'm going to start
something called ghcis ghci is a ripple
you know redevelop print loop where i
can just add hog interact with values uh
in in haskell
um and
again don't worry too much about the
syntax it's more like what can you do
with the values here so there's a little
bit of color going on here and it's
quite busy to look at so um i'm just
gonna you know simplify the prompt a
little bit here so i'm just going to say
it's going to look like this
and i'm going to clear clear clear the
screen here so i can do something like
that all right
so the first thing i want to do is i
want to load that file so
again don't worry too much about the
syntax
there's a built-in
function of build an action called read
file and i just need to to find
my file on the desktop so it's something
like users
mark
disk top
log.txt
all right so that reads the file so if
if not if we don't see any exceptions
that just worked if you're wondering
what ill is it l is just the log
it's just the contents of that file and
it looks quite unreadable here so we
want to pass it we want to interpret it
into something that i actually proper
haskell
values um so the way that i can do that
i'm going to create a new
value called replay data and the way
that i'm going to do that is i'm i think
i have a
a function or an action already this is
a function
that's called read
replay
ah replay let's say replay something
like read replay data from a log okay so
if we look at what that looks like
replay data
that looks a little bit more um
you know it's a little bit more readable
still quite you know abstract but we
have all the information and that now
they're actually at haskell values it's
like you know if you didn't listen to
sharp now you actually have c-sharp
objects this is a collection of objects
basically so for example if we're
interested in if we want to see what was
the reservation that was actually locked
i'm going to need that later on so i'm
going to call that r
so i can get the head of that's just the
first element in a collection of
something called observations of
post reservation you know from that
replay data
so there's my reservation
so let's let's clear out this as well
it's it gets a little bit busy
so let's start here again so let's let's
just re you know this is the reservation
that is in the log we've now passed it
and i have access to it so if i'm
wondering what happened i'm not really
but just you know if in case i am i know
i
talked about this function called try
accept before so i can try to ask you
know what's the type of that so when i
go colon type i'm not trying to run the
function i'm just you know
basically looking at the type of it and
saying what's the type of it and and
that looks really complicated but
basically what it turns out is that it
needs a reservation as well as one of
its input arguments and then it needs
something else and there's something
else is the
seating duration
so this restaurant has a seating
duration where you have a table for a
couple of of hours and then you have to
leave the table because there might be
other people and then we also have a
table configuration and i can read that
from a config system that i have already
and so i do that so seating duration is
something called a nominal diff time
that is basically the same thing as a
time span uh in the in c sharp so that's
just the duration this is 9000 seconds
that's two and a half hours
tables it's the table configuration from
the restaurant so this restaurant has
four tables it has a table for two it
has a table for four for six and four
eight so i thought that was easy to
remember because that becomes important
a little bit later on so now i have
those values so what would happen if i
try to call i can i can sort of ask the
type system you know if i try to call
with the seating duration
and with the tables and with the
reservation then
i lost the okay and then it came back
okay so what it would give me is this
horrible looking thing here except t of
blah blah blah blah
and you don't need to understand exactly
what that is except for that it is a
pure value it is it is not something
that is impure um but but the pure value
actually describes a little program in a
little dsl and you need an interpreter
to run over that program in order to
figure out you know what's actually
going to happen this is how you
interleave pure functions with impure
actions and what happened when i ran the
actual code was that that interpreter
then went and interacted with the
database
but what i can do now is i can i can
define another interpreter that instead
of interacting with the database it's
going to replay what happened in the
logs so i have another function here
called replay
i think it's called replay yes
and um it takes a the replay data that
we already have and it takes one of
those except t horrible looking things
and then it produces a pure value and
something called an either value that
indicates whether it's a success or a
failure that's basically how that works
um so you notice all of these are pure
functions there's no nothing that says i
o here so the replay
would be a pure function
so what we can do is i can find the try
accept here and i can say let's replay
that
um
with the replay data that i have
and i just need to put a little simple
there and it produces the value right of
nothing so that basically just you know
you know repeated the execution that
happened on the server based on on the
on the log data and you know if it seems
a little underwhelming that it just you
know the output is right of nothing it's
because this was you know trying to save
something in a database and that's all
about the side effect and the side
effect doesn't really produce any output
or it can but you know we didn't do that
in this case so there's no output it
just means things went well there was no
output
fine okay
so um
so the point the point of this is again
it's not that i really tried i'm not
trying to convince you that you should
write all your production code in
haskell
but it's it's interesting to do those
kinds of proofs of concepts because we
learned something about you know what is
pure
what can be pure and what has to be
impure and
what we've learned here for from this
little proof of concept is that the
impure actions in a system like this one
is first of all the database um and the
system clock now this is not surprising
you know if you've done this sort of
exercise a couple of times you will know
that databases are always impure because
they involve io and the system clock is
always impure because they're not
determined it's non-deterministic
so but there might be other sources of
impurity as well but in this state of
the of the application uh that's that's
basically what we have to deal with
so in order to have you know
in order to figure out what to log
basically what what we've learned so far
is that
we don't need to log what happens inside
of a pure function because we can always
just re-run the function
but the things that we can't just re-run
is all the stuff that's impure because
that is non-deterministic or may have
side effects so that's the stuff we need
to log
no more than that but also no less than
that we need all the impure
things logged but that's also going to
be enough and that's sort of like what
that little replay demo also
demonstrated
so
what we can now turn our attention to is
once we know that you know we can think
about you know how do we then do that
in a sane manner and not like this you
know all of those log statements that
are sprinkled all over the code that
just makes the code really unreadable so
so that's not what we want to do
so
i also wrote the code in visual studio
and see sharp so we can now try to have
a look at that
and
the
the post method that i think is more
readable is is this one here
so um it doesn't look like it's logging
but it is and and the way that it works
is you'll notice for example that
it's not accessing datetime.now it's
doing something called
clock.getcurrentdatetime
and if you know the.net api you're
saying what's that i've never seen that
before because normally you do
daytime.now
so if you go to the definition here
you'll find that this is actually a
method on an interface an interface
called i clock
and and i define this interface because
i know the the
system time the clock is
non-deterministic so i need to hide that
behind an interface
so that's one thing also it turns out
that the database interaction so for
example if i'm reading the reservations
here if we go and have a look at that
that's another interface this is a
repository interface that defines read
reservations and it also defines a
method called create
so you probably um you know most people
will will probably have some data access
that's hidden that's hidden behind an
interface already so that should be sort
of
you know not surprising
and if we want to see you know what what
kind of classes implement that interface
first of all we'll find something that
is not surprising at all we have a class
here called sql reservations repository
and if we just try to scroll a little
bit we'll see
we have some sql code actually sitting
here
this could also be based on an orm it
doesn't really matter but it's just like
this is the thing that actually talks to
sql server
so that's not surprising at all
now it turns out though that if you
add other things that um that implement
that interface there's another one um
there's one con log reservations
repository
and this this one also implements the
interface but it does that by taking an
inner one
and wrapping around that so this is a
design pattern known as the um it's the
decorator design pattern
and and if you're wondering okay so
what's the inner one
we can go and look at the place where we
actually create this thing and you'll
notice it's not surprising that the
inner one for log reservations
repository is actually that sql thing
here but it might be something else but
you know that's that's the way that we
use that i usually configure those
things so inside of the log is is
sitting the sql implementation
so um
so what happens here with the create
method for example is that you know i
take the reservation then i log that
this interaction takes place and then i
call inner.create and this is a void
method so it doesn't return anything
but the same thing goes with the read
reservations thing here um i'm taking
i'm calling in a resume inner dot read
reservations first
and then i have the output of that i
locked that this interaction took place
you know what was the input what was the
output and then i returned the
reservations
and i do the same thing with the system
clock we can very briefly look at that
if we're interested there's a system
clock implementation that just you know
delegates to daytime.now but then it's
decorated by this lock clock
that
not surprisingly just locks that we
accessed uh the
the current time and what what the time
was at that point
all right so um so i have the system
running already so i should be able to
go and interact with it and see if if
that actually works
so it's running on a different port and
i just need to figure out what that port
is
so it's sitting right here and if you're
wondering why it looks like there's an
error at the moment it's just because
this is a proof of concept it's a very
thin slice through
the entire system so so this system
actually doesn't support you know http
get requests it only supports a post and
that's why we see that this um this 404
error here this is entirely expected i
just needed the um the port number so i
can try to basically reuse that um that
request from before just with a
different port number uh maybe just to
keep things a little bit more
interesting we should change the name
here so instead of you know having ill
making the um
the reservation
it would be her brother rain and so
we'll have you know rainbows here
instead of of elbows
so if you remember the table
configuration of this restaurant it has
table for two table for four for six and
four eight so now we're trying to make
another reservation on the same date on
the same time for two people now that
should still be possible because we have
a table for four maybe not good business
for the restaurant but you know if if
they don't have any other reservations
that could work
now what i did here is that i actually i
introduced you know deliberately a
little bug in the system um
so um so if i try to actually run this
it's it doesn't work
oh no
you know you'll notice here it says you
know internals 500 internal server error
couldn't accept
what went wrong
there's a bug in the system how can we
troubleshoot that
uh if only there were logging let's see
where do we put the log we can just put
the log in the file there you can see
there's this thing called log.txt here
so yeah we actually like what happened
that was that's fortunate and let's just
clear this and have a look at it so
what's inside log.txt well um in this in
this sharp demo here i decided to do
that as a json document instead of this
you know haskell um you know code
instead because that's easy ng-sharp but
but the idea is the same
we have all the data that we need in
order to figure out what what actually
went wrong so what i can do with this is
i'm going to move that log file to my
unit testing you know library so booking
api.unit tests and i'm going to call it
repro1.txt
so just you know moving moving the file
there and then if i go and have a look
at my code in um in visual studio if i
scroll down and have a look at my unit
tests
you can see repro.txt is sitting is
sitting right here and one thing i
actually want to do straight away is i'm
just going to make that an embedded
resource um and it's it's basically
because i actually want to read the
contents of that file and when doing
that from a unit tests it's you know i
think it's easier to just make it an
embedded resource and read it from there
because otherwise you need to manage
actually moving files and copying files
around it making sure that they're
cleaned up afterwards and so on your
mileage may vary but that's that's what
i usually do so i'm going to add add a
new test class here and want to be able
to reproduce this problem here so i'm
going to add a class called repros
and
make it a public class
i'm using xunit.net so
i have to decorate it with this effect
attribute here
and let's say
public void i'm just going to call this
repro 1 as well
so this is the first repro that i want
to do so the first thing i want to do is
just load the log from that embedded
resource so i can i and i did cheat a
little bit so i have you know an api for
that
so i'm just going to say okay i'm going
to load repro 1.txt
from that embedded resource there so ill
let's call it log that's a little bit
easier so l is just a string and you
recall that that string is actually a
json document
then now the next thing i want to do
then is i want to have a system under
test i want to you know be able to
create you know and
an object and test this and i also need
to read the um the data transfer object
the dto from the log so what i can do
here is i'll show you how this works
afterwards but i'm basically i have a
little api for that as well where i say
load load the reservation controller
post scenario and then what it does it
returns back the system under test
that's my reservations controller the
one that has the post method and then it
also gives me a dto that was passed out
of that log file so that's the
reservations dto
object
and i can now
you know exercise my system under test
so i can say post that dto you know so
again
i'll remind you the dto is passed from
the
um
from the log file and then you know
what's actually supposed to happen you
know this um this actual here is
something called an action result
so i want to say that this should be
assignable from something called an ok
result because i would expect this to
work i also know that it didn't i'm
going to need to import a namespace here
i also know that it didn't so if i try
to run my tests now i would expect this
one to fail because that was a bug in
the system and and it does it actually
does fail
so it says you know i expected you know
i expected an okay result but i actually
got an object result and
and if you if you try to sort of examine
that object results you'll you'll figure
out or you'll find that it actually
contains a 500 internal server error
with the message couldn't accept so
that's how that works so we now have a
nice repro of of things here
and i can show you in a little while
exactly how that works but but the nice
thing about having a repro is that now
you can actually start troubleshooting
so um
i know so i deliberately made this this
little piece of sabotage here so um
um so i know where to go and look for it
so the d the defect is actually sitting
around here so i'm just going to add a
break point just to prove a point here
so i can i can add a breakpoint i can go
back to repros i can decide to go and
debug that particular test
and
and i'm gonna wait a while because
that takes some time let's see i think
we hit the um
the break point now
so um so what's what's happening when
we're running this test is that it's
using the log information to replay what
actually happened and then you know at
this point we are going through a loop
and trying to find the index of a table
that can fit the um
that can fit the the the the reservation
that we're interested in and we find the
index it's the first uh you know it's
the first
table in the collection in the in that
array so the index is zero
um so we've actually did find it but
then you know so we say okay so we found
the table uh that means we can remove
the tables you know down here we can
remove that the table or that index oh
no it returns false and it you know we
have an off by one error here um so it's
it it shouldn't have been you know less
than or equal it should just have been
less than so now we understand what the
problem is and you know i i knew that
because i actually deliberately
introduced this bug but the point is
you can you can actually use the
debugger or you can use all your other
you know troubleshooting skills because
now you have a you know a deterministic
repro of the problem and then once you
find the problem you also have a nice
reprotest that you could that you can
then run and um and see that you've you
know
you now fix that you know that
particular defect
so how does this work um
let's go back and have a look at the
repro
so what happens inside of this method
here is that it it takes the json
document and it starts to pass that json
document and
it looks at all the different operations
that it encounters
and
and you know sorts them out into various
different collections and uh and then it
creates some replay implementations of
those uh
those interfaces so it's probably
easiest to understand the replay log uh
the replay clock sorry so when you
initialize the replay clock you take all
the observations that you've seen in the
log file of you know whenever the system
is asking for the current time you you
put that in a collection this is an
innumerable of date time you pass that
to the constructor of the replay clock
it creates a queue out of those because
they they should be in order and then
every time we call getcurrenttime
this is that's the interface method we
dq one of those values that that comes
from the log file and we return that
so that's how it's replaying
what happened and the same thing
basically is true for the repository it
looks a little bit more complicated but
basically the idea is the same when we
call read reservations so read
reservations might be called called with
you know more than one date time so the
first level of um
of data that i have here is a dictionary
where where i index into the dictionary
and say okay i want the entry in that
dictionary that con you know that
corresponds to this particular date and
i may have may have seen more than one
observation of that particular date so
inside of that you know dictionary entry
there's a queue because there might be
more than one observation of that query
and then again i dequeue one of those
values which is an iono mobile of
reservation and then i return that
so so these are two things you know the
repository here which is a replay
repository and the clock which is a
replay clock
i now pass them as dependencies i inject
them into the reservations controller so
when the reservation controller and all
sorts of other things that might you
know want to interact with those things
when it comes methods on those classes
it replaced what was in the log
so that that's how that works
right
okay so we're pretty much done um
so just to summarize we really favor
pure functions because pure functions we
can always just
re-repeat that execution to get you know
the the result if we know what the input
to the pure function is
when then we also know what the output
will be we can just run the function
again so we want to have as much pure
code as possible because all the stuff
that happens in pure code um
we don't need to lock that what we need
to log is the impure actions in this
case we saw one example was the system
clock we want to log all of those
accesses and also you know we are
accessing these the database we want to
log that as well so the way that i do
that i'm using this decorator pattern
where i'm wrapping the actual
implementations in another
implementation of the same interface
that then performs the locking you know
the decorator design pattern
so basically in order to to do this
there's um
well you sort of need to move towards a
functional paradigm because otherwise
you're just going to have a lot of
impure and pure code interleaved
but but if you can do it uh here's the
here's the recipe so first of all
identify all the impure actions so in
this case it was the system clock and
the database
make you know model those actions as
polymorphic types you know an interface
or base class because otherwise you
can't use the decorator design pattern i
just stick with interfaces so make
interfaces out of the database access
make interfaces out of the you know
accessing the system clock if you have
other things if you need to send emails
you need to hide that behind an
interface as well if you want to
generate random numbers you know you
need to hide that behind an interface
and once you've defined all of those
things that are impure you know behind
an interface you know use a decorator
design use the decorated design pattern
to you know
lock from the decorator and that means
when you're using one of those
polymorphic types there's no locking
noise in your actual code it just
happens automatically that you know
whenever you're doing something impure
it's being locked and to um to a lock a
lock
destination somewhere and then you know
profit basically uh use the logs to
enable replay so it's just to make sure
that that i get my point across here
it's not that i
it's not that i actually recommend that
you create one of those replay
machineries that i just showed you here
the reason why i showed you this replay
stuff is just to get the point across
how deterministic it actually is if you
have the right amount of information in
your log now i didn't do that when i
worked for that company that i talked
about you know seven or eight years ago
what we did was basically just look
through the logs and then we all there
was always enough information in the log
that we understood but you know we could
get an understanding of what the problem
was and then we could go and re and
write a unit test that reproduced what
happened at at run time you know maybe
using some of the data that we could
pull from the log
so it was more like an ad hoc process
you know go and look at the logs you
know maybe take some copies of the
things you know write a repro you know
and then run that one so it's not that i
have you know this fancy machinery this
was just to get the point across
but that's basically um
what um what i have in mind for for this
talk if you if you want to see more of
the details of how that works you can go
to block the plot.dk and you know find
the archive search for repeatable
execution and i have a little blog
series with three blog posts that that
walks you through that and shows you
some more of that code
so if you're interested in that you can
find it there and all free
you can also also go and buy some of my
books if you'd like to and in code that
fits in your head i talk a little bit
about that but actually most of the
details are on the blog so that's
probably where you want to go an amount
of time that fits perfectly because i'm
also out of slides and out of content so
thanks for coming